por la crisis sanitaria nuestra cita con
la cultura no está en estudio sino en
casa y hoy arrancamos con un gran
estreno la adaptación de la novela and
the devil of the time de ronald rate
pollock por parte del neoyorquino
antonio campos para entrar en situación
este drama sureño toca la historia coral
que va desde el fin de la segunda guerra
mundial hasta los años 60 y la guerra de
vietnam el contexto bélico pesa pero
quienes generan un tono cruel y de
violencia son unos personajes cruzados
que en si respiran muerte a ausencia de
ley y un dios que se hace difícil que
exista básicamente porque hablamos de
tragedias y crímenes encadenados que
ocurren durante décadas y en este punto
cada trama pueda acabar asfixiando
requerir más profundidad o incluso la
violencia ción del libro es tom holland
quien sobresale y entrega mejor cada
dosis demostrando que es más que
spider-man mientras que robert pattinson
crece en su rol de predicador asumiendo
lo desagradable del personaje
en el mes de mayo
con títulos bajo la ventana
son de su sangre
[Música]
para algunos este guión no podría haber
funcionado mejor como miniserie tal y
como es the third day que nos lleva a
otros estrenos en un registro inhabitual
youtube nos adentra en una isla de la
que busca escapar de una herida
emocional si bien contra sus deseos está
se agranda y revela otros peligros que
se explican con estaciones y otros
personajes que a la vez se dejan
embrujar por la isla
[Música]
tensión que no decrece en rachel también
definida como el paso de mildred de
enfermera a monstruo
ryan murphy rescata de la película one
flew over the cuckoo's nest este
personaje que interpretado por sarah
paulson muestra que el horror se hace no
se nace con él y aquí se expresa en una
perversión del sistema de salud mental
en otro registro explorando el amor nos
habla el luca guadagnino en why are you
want la definen como sería adolescente
por sus euforia si angustias pero uo
fraser y cat link nos llevan por una
sexualidad muy diversa que choca porque
tiene lugar en la base militar en la que
trabajan sus padres en el caso de fraser
sus dos madres el escenario italiano en
un entorno o estadounidense conquista
porque es la estética de guadagnino
mientras que lo mejor son las vidas
interiores de cada personaje
ahí estoy yo
el streaming no sostiene a falta de
cultura presencial una balanza que río
de janeiro está reequilibrando este
septiembre con row words saben que
brasil es poco de arte callejero junto a
chile colombia y méxico y desde esta
seña 18 artistas del país están pintando
16 murales gigantescos para hacer de la
zona portuaria de río uno de los polos
más grandes de street art
walls nació a partir de la necesidad de
dar voz a algunos puntos de la ciudad
por eso siempre pensamos en dar un nuevo
significado a los espacios urbanos
solemos decir que el arte es sólo un
complemento del proyecto y que el gran
protagonista es la ciudad el proyecto de
la productora vision arts busca reflotar
esta región no sólo para darle 1.5
kilómetros de color sino para barrer ese
gris ese abandono que dejaron los juegos
olímpicos de 2016 y ahora la pandemia
ponen ya los artistas crean de noche con
plataformas móviles y la colaboración de
favelas vecinas
rue awards quedará listo el día 27 al
lado del graffiti de eduardo cobra
record guinness del más grande del mundo
nuestro propósito es revitalizar una
parte del río que está olvidada es como
un no lugar un punto por el que la gente
pasa y nadie le presta atención era un
desperdicio estábamos cerca de dos
favelas morro de tinto y morro da
providencia muchas personas que trabajan
en este proyecto viven en ellas así que
no ven esta transformación de lejos sino
que están haciendo parte de ella es muy
bonita
en otros temas el prado devolverá a luís
elizabeth beisel hubo el honor que
merece al sacar de su almacén dos de sus
óleos aún deben pasar un último estudio
pero si son noticia es porque la
convertirán en la séptima mujer en ser
expuesta en sala vi hielo pon fue una
virtuosa retratista francesa que logró
fama por pintar a maría antonieta y que
cosechó aún más fama por su vida al
exilio pese a sus éxitos no pudo
deshacerse de esa unión con la monarquía
que restó a sus obras de mujeres y que
no le valió retrospectiva en francia
hasta hace cinco años
mientras que recordamos que por primera
vez en 24 años el festival de música del
pacífico petronio álvarez será virtual
del 22 al 27 de septiembre integrando al
público y agrupaciones más allá de
colombia la guinda final la pone el
cantautor español marc one que en su
nuevo disco el viejo boxeador incluye
una canción que no solo es una respuesta
al odio de los haters de las redes
sociales sino también a los límites que
no nos ponemos en la vida para
protegernos del menosprecio y darnos el
derecho de enfadar nos o defendernos
gracias por la compañía y cuídense
gracias
en defensa propia
también me lleva
[Música]
cuando muerde
nos sonríen
[Música]
pero no es así